this is an 8 news now breaking news  alert and we wanted to get back to that  breaking news and update you we are  closely following an officer-involved  shooting in the northeast valley metro  officers on the scene again this is near  pecos and lake mead that's where we find  madison kimbra who just arrived on the  scene madison what can you tell us  officers authorities excuse me are  investigating an officer-involved  shooting right here on pecos near lake  mead this happened about an hour ago and  we do know that the suspect is in  custody metro says no officers were  injured in the incident we're working to  learn more details as to what happened  you can see it's still an active scene  waiting for a media briefing hopefully  we will give you more details coming up  very soon reporting live madison  kimbrough live local now